the prime minister marked his first year
in office clutching crabs for the camera
in scotland his leadership was forged
in the heat of brexit and both he and it
have survived the pandemic now boris
johnson
is facing growing support for
independence in scotland
and he came to deliver a blunt message
you know we had a referendum on uh on on
breaking up the union uh a few years ago
i think only six years ago that is not
uh that is not
a generation by any computation and uh i
think what people really want to do
is see our whole country uh coming back
strongly
together in selkirk
on the scottish borders they're only
slowly coming out
of lockdown the conservatives won this
constituency from the snp
last year and two-thirds of the votes in
the independence referendum were to stay
in the uk i think i'll have a gallons
peak
in a busy butcher's shop on the high
street this 27 year old
who voted for independence in 2014
watched the prime minister's message and
didn't like it
once we had the first one and that was
it i thought right well that's we could
put it to bed now
sort of thing but you know nicola
sturgeon seems to be pretty adamant that
we should be an independent scotland
so we want to see what she says first
and see what she's
usually put in a good case
meanwhile for the customers yeah i
haven't seen that
boris johnson's message only reaffirmed
their divide
i don't want the independence i think
we're better in the uk
every country has its own choice should
be able to make their own choice
and who is he the reason i'm going to
wear this mask is because
you are all part of one couple the prime
minister
insisted his government's pandemic
response
has shown the might of the union but he
knows nicola sturgeon's snp
look likely to form a majority
government in next year's elections
and won't be surprised at her scathing
response
it's not how i would be choosing to
spend my time giving what we are facing
right now um and you know people can
make up their own minds
about these things about where they
think the decisions that we're having to
take right now
are best taken
[Music]
the conflicting messages for scotland's
voters
about the union have changed little
since 2014.
now both sides argue the pandemic
has strengthened their hand
gerard tub sky news